kyoro touching base with you a week on
it's been a period of transition for all
of us I'm learning new technologies like
zoom and using those video conferencing
technologies to keep in touch
making rickielee with council senior
staff everyday councilors local MP in
rate payers who want to talk to me about
issues of concern all their staff of
transition to working from home in to
doing a fantastic job supporting our
community in the essential services that
are required through this time and it is
a period of transition with waste in the
services there making sure that you're
supported and as much as possible
business as usual certainly appreciate
that for some people there are issues of
of a welfare nature and if there are
those please make contact with our civil
defense on eight hundred nine six five
four six eight and we can see what we
can do to support you through this
period I also understand that rates as
an issue but if you have issues in terms
of the next rating and voice that comes
out please make touch base for this so
we can see what we can do to support you
through this in the best way of
contacting us as oh eight hundred nine
six five four six eight for the next
year's annual plane cancers of our staff
to look at this and we're we can make
savings so we expect to be able to
communicate with you in the coming weeks
is to some of our thinking in their
space I've just asked like to ask you
all to spear a thought for essential
service providers police ambulance
pharmacists doctors and supermarkets
they're all doing a magnificent job
supporting our community and on behalf
of the y mae curry district i'd like
just like to extend my thanks to them
all for the service that they're
providing in the many others that I
haven't mentioned
as it comes into the weekend just to
speak to you about taking care of you
and your families for me I'll be
hopefully getting in the bitter
gardening which as much needed when I
look at also I go for a daily walk so
I'll be hoping to be out in the V out
with it and I've been it's great to see
many of our community doing it as well
and exercising what I call the tooth the
bypass of each other so look just take
here and stay home stay safe and
together we'll get through this virus
you